so this book that you wrote
yeah
um for your son
and a book that i have for my daughters
is truly
remarkable how did it come about um why
came about when i was uh when we all
were
uh in the middle of the pandemic and uh
and black lives matter
and
i was uh
discussing the the situations with my
with my 13 year old son walker 12.
and uh
and it just came to me that
it didn't seem like there was much
material out there that dealt with this
type of
subject matter so i wanted to write this
book and hopefully give parents and
children an opportunity to to talk about
these these issues that
that aren't that don't have a right or
wrong answer that the you know the
answer isn't that
well
this is the book you need to be reading
to your children it's so wonderful
it's so beautifully written tay it
really is
thank you i really appreciate that it
just it's so wonderful now um switching
gears a little bit is it true that when
you were doing ally mcbeal
that you hung out with my girl lucy lou
as the song goes
yes uh oh my god so embarrassing i had a
huge huge crush on her and i finally
got her to to go out
with me i think we're gonna go see some
theater and um
back back in the day i used to get
really really anxious so i go and i pick
her up
so i was already nervous then my anxiety
hit and as i was driving
i remember making a left turn
on laurel canyon and i was so nervous
that i was driving on the wrong side of
the road
and lucy went wait hey hey when i tried
to play it off like like i meant to do
it but uh i think i just
ended up telling her that i was just
really really nervous
so i'm very embarrassing but i got i got
through it all right now it is
valentine's day and uh if you don't mind
will you play a little valentine's day
edition of the final five for me yes yes
yes it's tainting and the valentine's
day edition is the final five
do it
okay number one what's the best pickup
line to get someone's attention
oh
um i'm awful with pick-up lines hi
my name is tay
very tick-tock just be yourself
okay number two biggest red flag to look
out for on a first
date uh oh for me uh how if they're a
rude to the uh to the to the servers
couldn't agree more okay number three
what's the best song to play when
getting ready for a date which sometimes
is the best part
yes um
uh
uh uh what's the beyonce one oh the
single leg it's perfect you're right
great choice okay number four finish
this sentence i'll know she's the one
when
when uh i
have uh butterflies all day and can't
wait to see her
[Applause]
okay and number five what's the most
romantic thing you've ever done
flown across the country for a day
to to visit somebody yeah
well on behalf of all the ladies we say
thank you for those kinds of gestures
and just being you
thank you tay diggs and tay's latest
book why
a conversation about race is a must read
it is so wonderful also be sure to check
out his show all american the hit
returning to the cw on february 21st
[Music]
you